hello there welcome back to new
rockstars i'm eric voss and we just got
a new trailer for obi-wan kenobi on
disney plus six episodes starting may
25th i have sustained myself since
revenge of the sith mostly on ewan
mcgregor memes so i can't wait for a
weekly fix of these
i have a bad feeling about this so i'm
gonna react to this trailer give you my
first thoughts and then tomorrow in a
separate video will be my in-depth frame
by frame breakdown of all the details
and easter eggs and uh orimesh
translations that you might have missed
so let's take a look here we go
oh he's riding an eop
watch out for those farts
we lost
mars homestead it's young luke
look at that little sky hopper
walker i know it's t-16
[Music]
i can't believe they're using duel of
the bates
to hunting jedi
grand inquisitor
he looks pretty scary
jedi cannot help what they are
wow
their compassion
the jedi code is like an itch
he cannot help it
the inquisitors are gnarly in this
whoa
that's the music from the uh
that's the music from revenge of the set
the final duel
that was one hell of a trailer i have to
give it up the the use of the music the
stakes the intensity the fear that we
feel of being a fugitive a jedi on the
run from these terrifying inquisitors
finally we get to see the inquisitors in
live action and everyone will see how
terrifying this force truly is and yes
although the big draw of the show for a
lot of people is the fact that hayden
christensen is coming back as darth
vader obviously that's a big reason i'm
going to be tuning in as well we do not
need to see him in a trailer yet thank
god let's not show him yet all we needed
was just uh his iconic breath and that
john williams music sting from their
battle on mustafar mentally bringing us
right back there i thought it was
fascinating to use duel of the fates
which was such a needle drop back in the
trailers for phantom menace in 1999 i
mean this teaser just restores that
promise that we all felt when we were
revisiting that prequel era could we
also interpret this as the tease that
maul could show up on this show and i
say maul because he's no longer a sith
at this point in history he is alive now
maul does not know that obi-wan kenobi
is on tatooine we do not see maul learn
that until the rebel storyline which was
just a few years before the battle of
yavin which was about seven or eight
years after this okay so since the
timeline this is 10 years after revenge
of the sith nine years before a new hope
so as we see in this luke skywalker is
10 years old obi-wan kenobi is in the
middle of his exile as he's keeping an
eye on luke skywalker on the lars
homestead and now it seems like the
major threat of this show the great
antagonists are going to be this group
in star wars lore called the inquisitors
now the inquisitors were introduced in
star wars rebels the animated series
these are a group of four sensitive
beings who were trained by darth vader
to hunt down all the survivors of order
66 and at the top of that fugitive list
is obviously obi-wan kenobi they're led
by a guy called the grand inquisitor who
in star wars rebels was voiced by jason
isaacs and spoiler alert dies at the end
of rebels season 1 but that's years from
now right now we're seeing the grand
inquisitor really the height of his
power he's played by rupert friend who
is committing full ham to this role he
looks terrifying now a bit of background
on the grand inquisitor this guy while
introduced in season one of rebels was
actually retconned to be one of the jedi
temple guards who was involved with the
prosecution of ahsoka tano when she was
falsely accused of bombing the jedi
temple later on they figured out the
real culprit was barissafi but as a
witness to those events he saw the
corruption of the jedi ways he knows it
firsthand he was trained as a jedi
raised in that temple which is why it's
so fascinating to now hear him lecture
the other inquisitors describing the
jedi philosophy as a kind of sickness an
addiction a compulsion an itch that
cannot be scratched he uses this term
they cannot help it jedi cannot help
what they are the jedi code is like an
itch he cannot help it and since george
lucas originally conceived of the empire
as space nazis i cannot help but
interpret this as a parallel to the way
that the nazis talked about hunting down
jews and other undesirables they would
say things like they cannot help the way
they are so we have to purge them from
this world and now it makes the
inquisitors so terrifying they are
resolute in their ideology they don't
see themselves as evil they see
themselves as ridding the galaxy of a
kind of moral corruption and to hear
obi-wan admitting defeat say we lost the
war's over this guy only has one mission
now and that is to make sure that luke
skywalker sees no harm he doesn't really
care about his own self-preservation but
this video is brought to you by the
ridge the ridge wallet is light and
sleek and industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky old school wallets to make it look
like you're smuggling an 80s car phone
in your back pocket check it out there
are over 30 colors including carbon
fiber and burnt titanium it holds up to
12 cards and still has room for cash
card
and
gold
dollars this is what they call the black
damascus only the finest for my front
pockets every ridge wallet comes with a
lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it the wallets have over 40 000
five-star reviews it's made with an rfid
blocking technology that protects you
from those digital pickpocketers they
also have other cool products like this
commuter backpack it's weatherproof and
great for toting around a laptop this
month actually marks nine years since
the ridge started and they're
celebrating with a special sale so get
15 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge.com
new rockstars and use code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
now one of the main characters we see is
moses ingram playing riva who is another
inquisitor we don't know which
inquisitor though so in star wars rebels
we meet a few of the inquisitors in
addition to the grand inquisitor we meet
the fifth brother and the seventh sister
two inquisitors who team up to try to
kill kanan and ezra they're answering
the call of the eighth brother who is
actually searching for maul all these
years these guys show up a lot in the
darth vader dark lord of the sith comic
series which we should all re-read or
read for the first time going into this
series because it seems like they were
pulling a lot from that we also in other
literature meet the sixth brother he's
the one who tried to kill ahsoka tano in
the book but she actually defeated him
and used his red kyber crystals
purifying them turning them into white
which is why she now has twin white
lightsabers that's where she got those
kyber crystals it was from an inquisitor
one of the highest profile inquisitors
we meet is actually in the jedi fallen
order game spoiler warning if you ever
intend to play that game but the
antagonist story line trilo sunduri she
was a padawan of the jedi seer agenda
who actually gave away her location
turning trilla pretty pissed off she
becomes the second sister inquisitor but
she ends up getting defeated when she
tries to fight calcus at nerd and when
she temporarily uh uh shows uh some
forgiveness to see agenda vader kills
her that's actually how a lot of the
inquisitors die is vader's like i see
weakness and just slays them so yeah not
a good life for these guys so we'll see
with riva who knows she may be like the
first sister and it looks like we're
gonna meet a lot of other inquisitors
which makes this super exciting because
i thought it was brilliant how rebels
introduced them as the fifth brother the
seventh sister just implying that there
are so many more faces to fill into that
lineup now we see a lot of shots of a
new planet this planet is called daiyu i
think that's how it's gonna be
pronounced the writer of the show joey
harold described it as it sort of has a
hong kong feel to it it's a
graffiti-ridden nightlife it's kind of
edgy it's just a different lane and a
different feeling and when i read that
in the article i was like so are we just
gonna see another metropolis another
coruscant type setting but actually they
do a really good job just accentuating
the fog because hong kong is a is a
harbor city there's often a sea layer
that blows through it so you just see
this uh foggy background that's lit by
these uh aurabesh neon signs you know
i'm gonna be translating all those in
the breakdown don't worry i won't do
that here i need a moment and i gotta
say i i love that joel edgerton is
coming back as uh owen lars what'd it
get by george lucas back in 2005 for
someone who just seemed like a pretty
small character the fact that he's
coming back now after being a much
bigger star and a lot of bigger titles
it's just so great to bring him back
into the fold it looks like reba is now
on tatooine searching for obi-wan kenobi
and owen lars knows about ben kenobi who
knows about that whole backstory i think
it's terrifying to see someone suspended
from their feet down i don't think
they're going to be suspended from a
noose i think they're just being
suspended by the force but it looks like
now these inquisitors have discovered
the location of obi-wan kenobi and to
him that's an even bigger threat because
it could expose the link of luke
skywalker being the son of darth vader
something that obi-wan kenobi obviously
wants to keep a secret there's also some
rumors that in addition to seeing young
luke we may also see young leia in the
show which should also bring like jimmy
smith says bail organa back in that'd be
super exciting because there's got to be
a reason obi-wan leaves the planet a
tattooing this guy would never leave the
planet right he's here by a vow to
protect the skywalker lineage so the
only reason he would leave i think would
be to help leia in some other kind of
crisis folks just from the promises of
duel of the fates the possibility that
maul could show up in the series at the
height of his crimson dawn power than
not yet showing but promising a rematch
between obi-wan and vader we still don't
even know what hayden christiansen is
really gonna look like on this show
because they brought back hayden for a
reason if they just wanted vader in it
they could have brought in the team that
created vader for rogue one which was a
couple stunt guys and of course james
earl jones voicing him but to bring back
hayden christensen means we're gonna get
a peek under the mask whether that means
vader like in his breathing apparatus
egg thing or we're gonna see some look
under the mask like a close-up iron man
style or we're gonna see some weird
meditative astral plane version of the
character i mean speaking of which we're
all dying to see liam neeson come back
as qui-gon right because this is a
period where obi-wan kenobi's supposed
to commune with qui-gon jinn's force
ghost to learn how to become a force
ghost this is the show to do it i
couldn't be more excited for the show so
again my easter egg breakdown is gonna
come to the channel tomorrow and then on
monday tommy bechtold and i are gonna
dive further into the questions you had
on our weekly star wars reaction show
called wookie leaks join us every week
for that one of my favorite things i do
here at new rockstars you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you